merci Bernard jaumier de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de Paris à
parenté au groupe socialiste on va
parler de la fin de vie dans quelques
instants mais d'abord l'actualité du
jour c'est évidemment l'examen de cette
proposition de loi du groupe Liot à
l'assemblée qui sera examinée sans
labrogation de la retraite à 64 ans
déclarer receva pariel privé est-ce que
la bataille est perdue
bon c'est le dernier épisode
probablement le dernier épisode
législatif et effectivement voilà ça va
clore une séquence complètement
chaotique donc quand on prend un peu de
recul c'est un énième énième question de
procédure que le gouvernement a invoqué
via la présidente de l'Assemblée pour ne
pas étudier l'amendement proposé par par
les oppositions mais ça fait suite on se
rappelle à ce qui s'est passé au Sénat
ce qui sert à passer à assemblée je
crois que les Français maintenant ont
entendu parler d'un certain nombre
d'articles de la Constitution et des
règlements dont il n'avait jamais
entendu parler et tout ça est une
séquence très tout à fait détestable
pour notre démocratie parce que voilà le
gouvernement a utilisé abusé des
procédures pour faire passer à toute
force un texte qui est né dans de très
mauvaises conditions mais là elle a pas
raison de dire que c'est contraire à la
Constitution il y a le point de privé et
que ça crée une charge
à chaque étape on pouvait discuter à
chaque étape on peut discuter voilà
quand c'est un amendement effectivement
ça crée une charge mais quand c'est un
texte de proposition de loi et elle est
absentes c'était bien un texte
proposition de loi il y a vous le savez
une tolérance qui fait qu'on peut mettre
des charges supplémentaires en Lesage en
bon bah pas entrer dans la technique
mais et à ce stade là également le
gouvernement a fait pression pour que ce
ne soit pas recevable et si vous
remontez le fil ça a été comme ça à
chaque fois donc cette accumulation
d'artifice de procédure pour ne pas
étudier un texte et choquant parce que
si on prend du recul
mais si on prend du recul il n'y a pas
eu de vote on va dire or de l'engagement
de responsabilité c'est-à-dire une
procédure de contraintes très forte
dépassant le cadre du simple texte il
n'y a pas eu de vote de l'Assemblée
nationale qui représente le peuple il y
a eu un vote du Sénat mais dans notre
Constitution nous les sénateurs nous
avons une pleine part dans l'élaboration
et le vote de la loi mais nous
représentons les territoires et pas le
peuple et donc il est assez choquant que
l'Assemblée nationale
nous représentons les territoires dans
la Constitution et c'est né d'ailleurs
notre mode d'élection les Français le
savent n'est pas un suffrage direct ce
sont les députés qui sont élus au
suffrage universel direct par le peuple
et donc il faut que l'Assemblée
nationale à un moment puisse voter sur
ce texte elle n'a pas pu voter on sait
pourquoi c'est-à-dire que quand on
remonte tout ça comprend un peu plus de
recul on a un chef de l'État qui dit
cette réforme est légitime parce que
j'ai été élu et c'était dans mon
programme mais il oublie les conditions
d'élection et la démocratie ne se résume
pas un bulletin de vote tous les 5 ans
qui valident tous les textes qui vont
venir le problème c'est qu'il s'appuie
sur cette légitimité qui est faible et
d'autant plus que il n'a pas obtenu
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale donc on
a ce combo successif d'un président élu
surtout pour faire barrage à l'extrême
droite moi j'ai voté pour l'USSE gontour
comme beaucoup pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite puis une absence de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale ce qui
le contraint à utiliser toutes les
procédures il faut sortir de cette
situation c'est ça la leçon comment on
en sort comment on en sort est-ce que
pour en sortir il faut un accord de
gouvernement avec ceux qui le veulent
est-ce que le PS serait prêt à cet
accord je crois qu'il y a pas beaucoup
de solutions pour en sortir vous avez la
solution de retourner vers le peuple
c'est-à-dire de dissoudre l'Assemblée
nationale et on comprend que le chef de
l'État ne veut pas retourner vers le
peuple donc il ne veut pas dissoudre
l'Assemblée nationale et il y a l'option
d'un contrat de gouvernement
et pour ça il faut une culture du
compromis et c'est ça si vous voulez les
Français
lors des dernières élections
législatives ont envoyé un message à la
classe politique qui est pas de majorité
à l'Assemblée national donc
entrer dans une logique de compromis et
je le dis clairement le premier
responsable dans ce cas là c'est celui
qui est au pouvoir et Emmanuel Macron et
ses gouvernements n'ont pas voulu de
cette logique de compromis ils ont
préféré tenter des accords ou par coup
un peu bricolé sur un coin de table et
si on n'entre pas dans cette logique de
compromis politique on ne peut pas avoir
une stabilisation politique devrait y
rentrer dans cette réplique de son
premier politique selon je crois que vu
l'évolution actuelle du gouvernement un
accord cadre majoritaire avec la
majorité présidentielle de la part de
force de gauche comme pareil pas
possible on voit que sur les questions
fiscales et économiques c'est les plus
riches qui sont favorisés que la
transition écologique ne se fait que de
très lentement etc donc on voit plutôt
un gouvernement et une majorité
présidentielle qui se tourne vers la
droite donc l'exercice c'est un accord
entre la majorité présidentielle et les
républicains pour vous je ne suis pas en
train de je ne suis pas le porte-parole
des uns ou des autres ce que je dis
c'est que il faut soit dissoudre
l'Assemblée nationale soit clarifier et
allons au bout de la clarification moi
je dans ce cas-là je serai comme mes
amis dans l'opposition mais au moins les
choses sont claires parce que ceux en
même temps n'est pas un compromis ce en
même temps une déstabilisation
permanente de notre vie politique qui
fait des ravages et qui favorise les
extrêmes Gérard Larcher Premier ministre
ça serait une bonne solution pour sortir
de la crise pour vous
je n'ai pas à me prononcer sur qui doit
être ou serait Premier ministre mais
effectivement dans le cadre d'un accord
majoritaire ce président du Sénat de
savoir s'il veut entrer dans cet accord
majoritaire on va parler de ce qui se
passe au Sénat justement le gouvernement
qui prépare un projet de loi sur la
question de la fin de vie après les
travaux de la convention citoyenne un
texte que la ministre veut bâtir avec
les parlementaires les sénateurs
auditionnés justement cette semaine la
ministre Agnès firmant le Baudot et la
convention citoyenne on en parle avec
notre journaliste parlementaire Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour Oui Audrey vous
avez donc suivi ces deux auditions Sénat
sur la fin de vie celle de la ministre
Agnès Firmin le Bodo et celle des
membres de la Convention citoyenne sur
la fin de vie il y a eu des points de
convergence qu'est-ce qu'on peut en
retenir d'abord une première information
il y aura bien un projet de loi pour une
aide active à mourir et il sera présenté
avant le 21 septembre les travaux
d'élaboration commenceront à dès la
semaine prochaine la ministre la
confirmé elle a aussi dit qu'elle
prendrait le temps écouter
ce serait une procédure accélérée je
crois pas que sur ce sujet là il y a de
procédure accélérée possible on peut
aussi se dire que ces travaux
nécessitent du temps de la réflexion
mais des échanges mais je dois aussi
pouvoir dire qu'on ne part pas de nulle
part que il y a déjà eu beaucoup de
travaux qu'il y a eu beaucoup d'échanges
mais il faudra prendre le temps et on
prendra le temps
les débats au Parlement devraient durer
entre 12 et 18 mois et la ministre a
promis d'être à l'écoute des
parlementaires et des professionnels de
santé médecins et soignants précisons
que l'aide active à mourir ça englobe
l'euthanasie quand le corps médical
prend la décision d'abréger les
souffrances d'impatient et qu'ils
réalisent l'acte elle englobe aussi le
suicide assisté quand on procure des
médicaments aux patients mais c'est
ensuite lui qui exécute l'acte c'est un
sujet dont c'est aussi emparé à la
Convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
vous l'avez dit 185 personnes tirées au
sort qui représentent toutes les
catégories tâches socioprofessionnelles
de classe mais qui ne représentent que
même pas d'associations pas de partis
politiques ça permet d'avoir un palais
un panel et on apprend que 97% d'entre
elles pensent que le cadre
d'accompagnement de la fin de vie doit
être améliorée 75% se sont prononcés en
faveur d'une aide active à mourir preuve
que la société évolue écoutez
va mourir vient combler les limites de
la sédation profonde et continue
jusqu'au décès qui vous le savez qui ne
peut s'appliquer que sur une courbe
période de la fin de vie car les
médicaments utilisés ont un effet limité
dans le temps or certaines agonies
durent plusieurs jours voire dépasse la
semaine ce sont ces patients donc
Conseil d'État parle quand il écrit
qu'il n'en finissent pas de mourir pour
lesquels nous pensons que les actives à
mourir pourrait être une solution mais
le chiffre de 75% que j'ai évoqué un
petit peu plus tôt est à nuancer écouter
dans les 75% de gens qui sont pour
l'ouverture à l'aide active à mourir il
y a des gens qui sont opposés à
l'euthanasie d'autres qui sont opposés
au suicide assisté et en réalité le
socle de ceux qui sont pour l'aide
active à mourir
et le chiffre qui a été dit par ma par
ma camarade 40% qui sont pour
l'ouverture complète et à l'euthanasie
et au succès assisté alors le sujet
divise quand il est intime il faut
maintenant décider un modèle français on
ne sait évidemment pas encore à quoi ça
va ressembler mais le président de la
République a tracé des lignes rouges
l'ouverture de ce droit ne concernera
que les personnes majeures dont le
pronostic vital est engagé à moyen terme
disposant de leur plein discernement
alors Monsieur jovier on va parler tout
à l'heure des soins palliatifs mais déjà
est-ce que vous êtes pour l'ouverture
d'un nouveau droit
comme beaucoup je constate que
l'application de la loi classe néonetti
sur la fin de vie est insatisfaisante et
je constate également que même si elle
était parfaite cette application il y a
un principe qui serait encore
insuffisamment reconnu c'est celui de
l'autonomie des personnes et donc de
leur propre capacités à décider et donc
je fais partie de ceux qui disent que la
loi doit évoluer comme vous l'avez
rappelé la grande majorité des Français
et après donc c'est à dire on doit
légiférer sur l'aide active à mourir oui
après comment c'est là que le débat et
devient beaucoup plus complexe et moi je
trouve très intéressant les travaux de
la convention citoyenne parce que ils
ont mis en lumière au-delà des chiffres
des pourcentages de ce que pensent les
uns et les autres ils ont mis en lumière
cette complexité et les choix qu'il y a
à faire et quand on met en lumière cette
complexité ces choix qu'il y a à faire
on voit que les citoyens sont partagés
et c'est ça que je trouve très très
intéressant c'est que jusqu'ici je le
dis pour ceux qui contestent ces
processus de démocratie participative
jusqu'ici on avait des sondages qui nous
disaient il y a 90% de pour et 10% de
contre et ben c'est faux la réalité
c'est que l'opinion publique les
citoyens quand on réfléchit qu'on pose
sur la table sur quel principe on veut
se fonder c'est quoi le respect de la
vie c'est quoi la mort c'est quoi la fin
de vie c'est quoi le rôle des soignants
dans notre société c'est quoi le droit à
choisir de chacun d'entre nous en tant
que citoyen et bien il faut maintenant
qu'on conjugue tous ces principes dans
une loi mais vous vous êtes donc pour
une évolution la comprime mais jusqu'au
suicide assisté ou est-ce qu'il faut
aller jusqu'à légaliser le thanazi
moi je fais partie de ceux qui pensent
que le principe d'autonomie doit nous
amener à accorder à reconnaître à chaque
citoyen le droit de décider à un moment
que sa vie doit s'arrêter pour des
raisons de souffrance etc etc et que ce
principe de dominomique se confondent à
d'autres principes et parmi les autres
principes auxquels il se confronte
pardon il y a le rôle des soignants dans
une société et le rôle des soignants
n'est pas
d'administrer la mort ça peut arriver
mais ce n'est pas un rôle qui doit être
codifié dans la loi et donc je suis
favorable au suicide assisté et je ne
suis pas favorable à la légalisation de
l'euthanasie on garde l’exclusion des
mineurs comme le veut le président de la
République alors je vais je vais être
très tranquillement dire que je ne veux
pas discuter des lignes rouges ce n'est
pas une bonne façon d'entrer dans le
débat c'est l'in un café la convention
citoyenne elle est entrée dans justement
les valeurs et ce sur quoi il faut
progresser et après il y a des limites
qui apparaissent et qu'on définit et ça
fait partie du cadre qui est nécessaire
pour éviter que le système dérive dans
tous les sens tous les pays ont adopté
un cadre mais on n'entre pas dans la
discussion à mon sens avec des lignes
rouges et dictées par un tel ou Intel
Audrey vous le disait il a beaucoup été
question de soins palliatifs dans ces
audition oui le gouvernement veut mettre
en place une stratégie décennale avant
la fin de l'année en fait ce qu'on a
appris lors de ces auditions ce que vous
avez un peu rappelé c'est qu'il existe
un texte la loi cess leonétique qui date
de 2016 qui complète la loi Leonetti de
2005 ce texte doit permettre un meilleur
accès aux soins palliatifs faciliter
aussi la rédaction des dernières
directives et la désignation de
personnes de confiance sauf que cette
loi elle est mal connue mal appliquée
12% des français seulement ont rédigé
leur directives anticipées et il y a
encore 20 départements en France qui
n'ont pas d'unité de soins palliatifs
elles ont ils ont des lits mais pas
d'unité complète un problème que le
gouvernement contre régler d'ici la fin
2024 écoutez la problématique c'est
qu'en unité de son palliatifs pour
certains hôpitaux c'est que
statistiquement on y décède
et donc fallait le faire le choix
d'investir pour accompagner vers
vers la mort et que certains ont préféré
investir dans d'autres domaines plus
curatifs parce qu'en France parce qu'en
France on a la culture du curatif et que
ne pas réussir à soigner ces vécus comme
certains par un échec et que le
palliatif est peut-être vécu comme un
échec et donc c'est les l'enjeu c'est de
développer cette culture palliative
cette anticipation palliative et donc
pour ça il faut former et il faut former
des études de médecine ce qui n'est pas
le cas on l'a dit on manque d'une
culture du palliatif en France mais 20
départements qui n'ont pas l'unité de
soins palliatifs comment ça se fait que
cette loi de 2016 n'est toujours pas
bien appliquée oui et c'est une grosse
interrogation et je ne crois pas un seul
instant que l'engagement de la ministre
que fin 2024 il y ait des soins tout le
monde est axé aux soins palliatif parce
qu'au-delà des la technique les unités
les équipes mobiles c'est là que ce soit
palliatif je n'y crois pas à l'instant
simplement pour des questions de
personnel
nous n'avons pas le nombre vous voyez
bien qu'il y a une pénurie de médecin
déjà dans notre pays donc je le dis
tranquillement si on estime qu'on ne
légifère sur la dactée à mourir que 600%
des Français ont accès aux soins
palliatifs je pense qu'on est différente
jamais et c'est une question d'autant
plus importante qu'elle est dans la vie
du CCNE c'est-à-dire qu'on vous relisez
la vie du Comité national d'éthique sur
cette question de l'ouverture de l'aide
active à mourir le CCNE nous dit il faut
d'abord que tout le monde ait accès aux
soins palliatifs et moi j'ai une grosse
interrogation là dessus
audrey elle disait
annoncé une loi avant le 21 septembre
qu'est-ce que vous attendez vous
précisément de cette loi alors le
processus donc de la loi va commencer
comme vous l'avez rappelé comme l'a dit
à ministre à la rentrée et heureusement
on sera dans une procédure normale on a
pu vraiment l'habitude et donc ça va
prendre deux lectures
au minimum une année plutôt un an et
demi qu'on arrive au vote final de la
loi
il faut que le débat se poursuive
pendant ce temps c'est à dire que le
travail de la convention citoyenne ça
n'est pas la fin pour moi il faut que
nous les parlementaires nous menons nos
travaux en interaction avec la société
il faut que ces questions des soins
palliatifs du rôle des soignants du
droit des personnes de la mort dans
notre société soit débattus pendant tout
ce temps-là pour permettre de maturer un
texte qui rassemble au maximum parce que
évidemment que quand on ouvre un droit
il ne faut pas reculer parce qu'il y a
des oppositions c'est normal dans une
société mais je crois aussi qu'il faut
écouter chacun parce que on touche à des
questions comme quand on discute d'une
loi de bioéthique qui sont profondes et
je fais ce parallèle avec la loi de
bioéthique pour une raison précise
d'ailleurs c'est qu'il est de coutume
dans notre pays que la loi de bioéthique
la révision soit votée par consensus
entre l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
il y a une exception dans la dernière en
loi parce que le gouvernement y avait
introduit une dysplosion qui n'a rien à
voir avec la bioéthique qui est
l'ouverture de la PMA au couple de
femmes aux femmes seules que j'ai
soutenu par ailleurs mais faut
reconnaître ça n'avait rien à voir avec
une loi de Beauty mais là moi j'appelle
à ce qu'on entre vraiment dans ce
processus parce que cette question de la
vanne de vie relève de la bioéthique et
que on mature un texte commun qui fasse
qu'on s'insus entre l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat merci Audrey oui
on va parler de la proposition de loi
Eliote qui examinait d'ici quelques
dizaines de minutes ce sera si bien
évidemment dans le club on va voir
l'actualité dans nos régions maintenant
Bernard Jaumet on va aller du côté
Damien retrouver Jean-Marc chevaucher
bonjour Jean-Marc merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous rédacteur au chef adjoint au
Courrier Picard et avec vous Jean-Marc
on va parler de la maternité de Péronne
dans la Somme qui est fermée jusqu'à la
fin du mois
de grosses difficultés Oriane dans cette
maternité puisque cela fait c'est la
deuxième fois qu'elle est fermée comme
ça ponctuellement la première fois parce
que il y a pas assez de d'anesthésiste
une autre fois parce qu'il y a pas assez
de médecins donc c'est au cœur d'un
bassin de population évidemment très
rural où la maternité rentre de nombreux
services et c'est dans une ville de 7500
habitants donc c'est pas c'est pas la
grosse agglomération mais vous imaginez
bien que dans ces secteur là quand il
faut faire beaucoup de kilomètres pour
aller accoucher c'est un gros problème
donc effectivement elle est à nouveau
fermée cette maternité
et Jean-Marc vous avez une question à ce
sujet à Bernard jaumier
écoutez ce qu'on pourrait demander et
puis s'interroger c'est c'est savoir
comment faire pour pour recruter des des
médecins ou des ou des professionnels de
santé dans ces secteurs-là ça devient
effectivement
très très préoccupant tout le monde sait
qu'il y a de nombreux sites qui sont
concernés en France et particulièrement
à Péronne évidemment on vit ici mais
c'est à peu près partout comme ça est-ce
qu'il faut voilà certains parlent de de
d'obligation d'installation qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire pour que pour que pour
que les médecins et les anesthésistes et
et au-delà parce que il manque aussi des
sages-femmes des infirmières viennent
s'installer dans ces dans ce secteur là
un peu moins c'est vrai
bonjour
comme vous l'avez noté c'est une
situation qui se présente dans de
nombreux territoires c'est même diffus
on va dire dans notre pays alors toutes
les professions dont vous parlez les
anesthésistes les obstétriciens ou ce
sont des médecins et on a une pénurie
profonde de médecins dans notre pays
actuellement et répondre à cette pénurie
c'est évidemment augmenter drastiquement
le nombre de médecins formés
et par ailleurs
la question de la répartition
est une question qui est complexe parce
que on a mis en place des mécanismes
incitatifs vous le savez qui ne
fonctionne qui ont produit des résultats
mais des résultats incomplets vous
parlez d'obligation d'installation mais
là on est dans une maternité on est dans
un salariat donc ça voudrait dire qu'on
passe dans un système en gros
d'obligation d'être salarié à telle ou
tel endroit et c'est ça peut paraître
séduisant mais c'est irréaliste on peut
voilà on peut on peut le regretter ou
sans féliciter peu importe c'est
réaliste ça ne pourra pas ça n'existera
pas dans notre pays
d'assigner telle ou tel lieu à un
professionnel un médecin et pourquoi
c'est réaliste
il y a d'ailleurs des textes qui vont
être débattus à l'Assemblée nationale
dans les prochains jours il y a deux
propositions de loi qui disent qu'on
peut réguler l'installation des médecins
quand on régule celle des pharmaciens
est-ce que c'est pas une bonne chose il
faut être précis les textes qui sont
proposés parlent donc de l'installation
en libéral donc vous pouvez dire à un
jeune médecin tu n'as pas le droit de
t'installer à Amiens
et ben il s'installera pas à Amiens mais
il ira dans un centre salarié à Amiens
où il fera autre chose donc vous
n'obligerez pas dans notre société
quelqu'un allait habiter là où il ne
veut pas c'est une fausse piste donc la
question est celle de rendre attractif
les endroits les différents endroits où
on peut exercer et donc les ce qu'on
voit c'est que l'hôpital a un problème
général d'attractivité pour deux grandes
raisons des raisons de rémunération et
les maternités et les secteurs
d'obstétriques sont particulièrement
concernés parce que on est toujours pas
réglé la rémunération de la nuit et des
weekends qui reste très insuffisantes et
le ministre lui-même le dit
et deuxièmement parce que les qualités
la qualité de vie au travail à l'hôpital
c'est dégradé que là où on demandait par
exemple à une infirmière de prendre en
charge 10 patients il y a 10 ans on lui
en demande d'en prendre la recherche 15
maintenant et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai fait adopter au Sénat une
loi sur les ratios patients soignants
c'est comme ça qu'on peut essayer qu'on
peut améliorer la situation avec toutes
les questions mais c'est très long d'en
parler d'attractivité de tel ou telle
territoire mais je le dis la question de
l'obligation de dire comme un certain
nombre de textes qui circulent
actuellement issus de parlementaire de
dire vous pourrez pas vous installer là
parce qu'il y a trop de médecins
déjà moi je dis que le maire qui estime
qui a trop de médecins sa commune lève
la main
merci Jean-Marc chevaucher merci d'avoir
éteint les experts du poil ne répond
plus c'est à la Une de votre journée ce
matin merci beaucoup Jean-Marc d'avoir
été avec nous un mot sur les
sénatoriales Bernard jaumier sénatorial
à Paris vous êtes candidats à votre
succession pas succession à votre
élection
exactement
c'était qu'il y a une liste commune de
les écologistes à Paris ah mais j'en ai
fait la proposition à votre micro pour
la première fois il y a plusieurs mois
je pense qu'il y a une majorité
départementale à Paris qu'elle doit
aller unie aux élections parce qu'on
peut gagner un siège de plus à Paris
c'est en bonne voie hier on avait
Yannick j'adopé qui est un des candidats
des écologistes qui nous disaient qu'il
était ouvert aux discussions est-ce que
vous croyez un aboutissement de cette
liste commune je pense que c'est
possible oui qu'il y a déjà un accord
entre plusieurs forces de gauche et
qu'il ne manque plus que élever et
j'aime moi j'appelle mes amis de LB à
rejoindre cette liste commune et ça veut
dire de séparer vous auriez s'il y a une
liste parce que là on est d'accord vous
êtes parti pour une liste socialiste et
communiste ça c'est acté les paris en
commun c'est-à-dire divers gauche
écologistes donc ça c'est acté et que la
question c'est de savoir si les
écologistes vont vous rejoindre c'est
très simple il y a 12 sénateurs et
sénatrices à Paris actuellement 7 pour
la majorité des départementales 5 pour
les oppositions qui sont droites et
majorités prisent si nous sommes tous
unis à gauche nous pouvons gagner un
huitième siècle que vous prendriez donc
à la droite absolument
est-ce que
Bernard Cazeneuve va lancer son
mouvement
ce sera du côté de Créteil est-ce qu'il
a raison Bernard Cazeneuve de vouloir
incarner cette gauche en tenue pour le
dire simplement ce que ce que je pense
un certain nombre de personnes à gauche
constatent et j'en fais partie de ces
personnes c'est que la forme actuelle
d'organisation de la gauche n'est pas
satisfaisante sa forme de représentation
n'est pas satisfaisante donc il faut
travailler à d'autres formes c'est ce
que fait Bernard Cazeneuve c'est ce que
font d'autres donc Harold Delga dont Ann
Hidalgo donc bon et c'est très bien
comme ça il faut progresser merci
Bernard jaumier merci beaucoup
arrêtez notre invité ce matin